[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we're answering your
questions that could be and are about
anything and I'm just man I hope you're
my hope this show goes well just you've
been mad it's not going to be because of
me I mean I freakin I'm I didn't eat
lunch I'm freaking starving
you're hangry I'm I got a bar here I
don't want to eat it on this show
because that's not professional and I'm
walking in I get the bar I go outside I
come back in and the freaking door that
hits me in the heel yeah and not just
like a little yeah I made some
adjustments to it you loosened it I made
some adjustments to the door the door
always closes slowly a little now I open
the door I walk in and it's and it's it
it it it shoves me in yeah by hitting me
on the heel by design I want people to
get in and get out quickly hurt man Phil
hey listen feel free to eat your kind
bar not a sponsor but a good bar I mean
could be a sponsor yeah we it would be
if they wanted it to be so now you can
talk about my chewing here it is hush
we don't you turn around be it do it do
us at all at a Zonday and turn away from
the mic when you chew okay pull away
from the mic because now hold on but
we've been talking about no I'm working
on my chewing volume like it I had a
Lincoln I actually had a what I would
call like a Jedi chewing training
session Dillo ASM on my packaging and I
didn't want to be offensive because I
realized that it's a slightly it's a
touchy subject when you're when you're
when you're trying to comment on
something that's so personal with
someone which the sounds that their
mouths make is about as personal as it
gets for a person so but as link and I
were sitting there eating lunch in our
office across from each other as we
often do I just said you know what if
you have you thought about maybe trying
to chew not so hard
here's
normal to you good gracious
that's just unadulterated that's me
that's not a horse that's actually less
intense than you typically do when
you're doing a thoughtless chewing like
when I like when I look at you and I
could tell that you're just your eyes
are off in nowhere you're just just some
wonky eyed chewing it's harder than that
I think I upset a Aadhaar base I am
angry summit channel it look off into
the distance like you're not thinking
about anything oh gosh that's it I mean
the the separation the the distance that
your that your mouth separates and comes
back together without opening that alone
is amazing to me thank you
but then there's also a pop which I
believe is a TMJ thing maybe I don't
know but it yeah there's definitely a
pop like almost on every - good again I
was trying to work it only works when
you've got material in there yeah you
got to give the wood chipper the wood
before the wood chipper becomes a wood
chipper otherwise it's just a chipper
it's so people you know what we do not
blame you if you've already left I'm
sorry we're not talking to you because
you're still here but here's one more -
I'm gonna try - I'm gonna try to eat
like a snake and just swallow it you
trying to go to the other end this into
the spectrum well these things are chewy
man yeah it would you I'm not
complaining right there might be a
sponsor one day
don't complain too much about it if you
do want to I'm chewing slowly it's still
noisy I can't do it what you're yeah
you're right up on a mic which is an
unfair way to test your chewing you need
to do it in a room as a normal person
you you eat this last piece normal up on
the mic sounds like a if I go into like
my Apple library to like use a sound
effect for chewing and be like that's
some gentle chewing I'm the one who did
the Apple sound but that was before we
were working together we always work for
your sauce jerk
I don't know how you do it ma'am well
and I don't want to know but as I've
told you before I'm worried that you're
gonna wear out your molars like an old
elephant and you're gonna die one day
you know they've got seven sets of
molars and once they get on that last
one you got to just let it die
or feed it pudding I love pudding I love
well I love chocolate pudding I love
vanilla pudding I love chocolate and
vanilla pudding swirl there it has been
a peanut butter pudding the chocolate
I've seen that and I like it or you know
I don't like a lot of other the puddings
but I do like I don't know that didn't
come out right but chia pudding I do
like that I had some of that today
actually you know I went to my my son's
not graduation but promotion they call
it because when you when you leave
eighth grade going to high school man
you go to the next thing you just get
promoted to it now I was dropping
Lincoln odd chia pudding after that they
did they have like a reception with chia
pudding yeah that's the thing now no we
went to a restaurant after to celebrate
and my wife ordered chia pudding at a
restaurant well it was after she had
already eaten breakfast okay I was still
hungry a chia pudding brunch type
situation I was dropping Lincoln off
late because I guess they would they had
the eighth grade promotion and then the
seventh graders were dropped off for for
two hours on the last day of school to
just sign their sign yearbooks and I
noticed yeah I was seeing 8th graders
and their parents leaving I was like
well that'll be me next year you know I
was at Hollis that's rhett and Jessi and
Locke now I didn't see you but I noticed
that a lot of people were dressed up and
I was like I'm gonna take a mental note
that when this happens to me next year
you're not gonna dress I ain't gonna
dress up I don't think you have to make
a mental note did you dress up you
should you know what I had on before I
put on this shirt yeah that's what I
wore if you call that dressing up no I
mean people look like they were putting
on like Sunday best I have all I got on
brown shoes though
I mean that's no it you look like you
were just coming into the office but
there were people who look like they
were going to a church service Locke did
wear a tie oh he did but he wore a shirt
untucked okay you know it was like cool
when he walk across the stage and get
handed a promotion yeah
700 students or something crazy like
that oh no and so they had an incredible
system that they had practice for hours
to get right you got people on each side
calling names in alphabetical order the
kids know exactly when they're supposed
to stand up like the different rows they
go out and they come back in it was as
quick as you can move through 700
students without just basically saying
should we just not do this at all right
it was clear that no one cared but they
just cared enough to know out of
obligation they had to do it and there
were some people who were so
enthusiastic even though you're supposed
to hold all applause to the end there
were some people who went really crazy
for their kid and it's just a thing I
turned to Jesse and I was like it's not
1920 getting through eighth grade is not
a big deal anymore and also it's illegal
not to so it's not like it's really an
accomplishment I'm sorry if that sounds
insensitive is that what you stood up
and yelled when yeah guys exactly this
isn't that big of a deal
it would be illegal if we did otherwise
uh watch out now that almost cheered me
up
also now this is really gonna cheer you
up you will never believe who did the
commencement speech at the 8th grade
promotion well do you want to do the yes
or no game Queen Latifah oh come on man
I wanted to frickin do the yes or no get
is it a musician yes
is it a rapper yes is it a female yes is
it Queen Latifah I could have got it in
three questions are you not amazed by
that well I'm disappointed that I didn't
get to arrive at it because I'm I'm
lying
of course Queen Latifah didn't do it it
was the principle hold on they didn't
even bring in a famous Queen Latifah
didn't do it no the owner of mini fat
burgers did not do the commencement
speech at my son's promotion because
again it's not a big deal Queen she is
honored of many fat
Berger's yeah Queen Latifah is not going
you were screwing with me stop managing
fat burgers that's not what she acted
oming and she's an actor she said she's
a musician she does all kinds of things
she's the queen next to Beyonce
now all I will say though is that she's
not going to divert her schedule to come
do something that is of no consequence
it's funny that I was so intent on
playing the yes or no game that you just
washed over Queen Latifah your lies
meant your dirty hip-hop lies you think
Queen Latifah would do that kind of
thing Queen Latifah would do a college
graduation if her if her daughter for a
pretty penny her son went to the school
yeah I think Queen Latifah is like a she
does speeches for hire that's what you
needed today with what you've been
through what have you been through by
the way why are you in a bad mood
I don't wanna well if you must know I
mean I told you I didn't eat yeah
because we got it that's it I just
didn't eat is that freaking stump I have
to leave at a certain time because I'm
going to my follow-up appointment for my
eye issue which I told you guys about
which everything is fine with the eye
but they were just like months down the
road we want to you know we got to do
the dilation and we want to you know we
want to check and make sure everything's
okay so I have to go to that not to be
there on time but you are intentionally
not eating I cook you haven't talked to
me about this but you you're doing I
heard you tell someone else because you
didn't want to tell me that you're doing
intermittent fasting I don't know what
that is except that you're not eating
well use the context figure out what it
is don't don't calm him down to me I
know I know what intermittent fasting is
I'm fasting intermittent when you you're
skipping dinner for for health reasons I
think well okay in first of all I'm not
doing it in any disciplined manner
because a I girlie accepted the kind bar
piece that you gave to me without any
protest and also what you're doing it
intermittently my parents are in town
and
I'm making scallops for him tonight what
I'm making scallops for him tonight
scallops scallops scallops scallops I'm
making scallops for him tonight
so give me and I'm you you can bet your
scallop I'm gonna eat some but give me
this just feel publicly that you didn't
want to give to me privately because you
knew I would just give you the stink eye
the whole time just because you don't
care about these kinds of things that's
fine but but I'm choosing to care about
it now okay because my question is if
you're going home intermittently and not
eating dinner for for health reasons
which I'm I'm semi curious about semi
curious I'm major curious I'm curious
for entertainment purposes not only know
that's my guess
okay you're the reason I'm in a bad mood
no it's the door I mean the foot but I'm
I'm I'm macho curious about mucho qjo
yeah macho curious that's about how
you're not angry at night if you don't
eat well you can get to that like that's
the thing I'm interested in okay well
but but we do need to know that well the
very offense a very quick thing is I'm
experimenting with intermittent fasting
because there's a plethora a cornucopia
if you will no I don't reach don't act
like I'm not gonna believe you I don't
I certainly believe you that suggests
that not only is it a good way I'm not
really interested it I always I have a
little bit of the of the of the spare
tire I've had it basically my entire
adult life and I'm as I crossed the the
threshold of 40 I just asked myself do
you think in your 40s you could get rid
of this and so it's sort of a personal
challenge to myself you were asking it
yeah I talked to it I massaged it and
what does I grab it it doesn't speak I
can however I mean I could get mold this
thing into the shape of a mouth that's
how much I got right there okay and it
is the last fat that you lose for
complex scientific reasons that I won't
go into but more you die
you is if you're trying to lose weight
typically your belly fat is the last fat
you'll lose because of the composition
of that particular fat however
intermittent fasting is not I'm not that
interested in weight loss what I am
interested in is longevity and
intermittent fasting has been shown not
only to be great for weight loss but
also great for longevity and basically I
don't understand all the science behind
it I just know that the evidence
suggests that if you if there's like a
16 hour 14 to 16 hour period per day
that you're not eating anything at all
you can you you're helping your body in
a lot of different ways avoiding disease
reducing cancer risk increasing
longevity and in general I don't like
knowing that I've got to stop what I'm
doing and eating it three times a day
because I've trained my body to do it so
I I'm actually open to this because I
don't like in principle being a slave to
well having to eat yes because what I
will say additionally is that the
principle of fasting has been a part of
different faith traditions for a long
time because it is a way of denying
yourself of this very basic need and you
kind of overcome it with willpower and
after you know ii-i've done like a seven
day fast not anything like in college I
did a seven day fast yeah and you do get
to some interesting places mentally a
few days in I haven't done that but what
I will say is that yes I get home and I
try to do this Monday through Thursday
and again I'm not disciplined if there's
a party if there's a get-together if
people are going out if not the parents
are in town a scallop involved if my
best friend hands me the butt end of a
kind bar I will break the fast it's not
a super discipline thing it's just a
general principle however what I have
found is that I do think that there is
something to saying I'm going to
overcome this desire to eat I'm not
gonna let it make me upset because I do
think you become a bit of a slave to
your body and its needs and you can kind
of beat the body back so that's you can
overcome it so do you like me have a
tendency to get really angry I don't
think I'm as I have a tendency towards
hang greenness to the degree that
headaches yeah I have gotten a few
headaches
yeah and I'll just pop a couple of
ibuprofen hopefully I try to breaking
your fast you're not eating pill I
pushed that off as much as possible
because I do think I'll adjust but if it
gets bad I'm like I'm not going to be
able to enjoy my nighttime activities
then I will have some ibuprofen okay did
you like that balls that I that I did
there after a night time I did oh I
don't like pauses in podcasts in general
because I'm like driving down the road
listen to a podcast all of a sudden you
think it's buffering it got it got quiet
for a second and what the filters that
not only else but most people put on
podcasts like it'll go like it's like
when you turn off the lights in a room
and it's a magically pitch-black room
mmm auditorially speaking that's very
shocking to me and I don't like it
that's why I like try to heavy breathe
okay good that was really just for the
people watching not those people
listening because I also made eye
contact with my camera that's my camera
anyway I'll report back later I I just
but I don't know much about it I've just
heard about it on a lot of podcasts I've
seen it a bunch of articles you see it
in the news all the time all the people
who seem to know what they're talking
about when it comes to the body and life
and health are singing the praises of in
a minute faster do you sit down with
your family and they're eating and
you're just sitting there like a bump on
a log
doing on IB pro/5 done that I have sat
down with them and had tea while they
were eating because you're not breaking
your fast if you're having tea
how convenient also the my family is so
not scheduled that everybody has
something in the evening so there was
only like one or two nights a week that
we all sit down together anyway so
hasn't impacted that a whole lot like we
get breakfast with the boys you know and
we see each other in the morning have
you had any positive results from your
intrument fasting to date I had a vision
okay no Queen Latifah I only made it
I've been doing it for like a month and
there's only been one Monday through
Thursday
stretch that I was consistent for all
four days so I felt good about myself in
that time but the funny thing I realized
is that if I was doing this ten years
ago like I'm working out almost every
day I'm doing like 45 minutes of cardio
I'm doing some reasonable weight
training be lean and mean huh it this
would be so gone but something about
getting to this age I know you guys we
talk about how old we are a lot but it's
amazing I have that how unresponsive the
spare tire is I can make it but not
ready I'm out I could do that I have
that too that could be a separate
YouTube channel just our belly mouths
talking to each other in 2006 that would
have worked okay I I feel I feel okay
now I feel like we can get closer to the
to the stated objective which is
answering any question that you have
given to us which is gonna lead to some
other stuff but first I want to let you
know where you can get this shirt that
I'm wearing yes we have created the
Daniel and Richard shirt is it is it you
on your own chest no it's Daniel and
Richard no relation to me that's a cool
frickin shirt man the only thing that
makes it not cool is the fact that it
looks like you're wearing a drawing of
yourself but you are playing a character
on your own shirt I just think it would
I should have worn it I don't think you
should go out in public like that but I
think everybody else should support
internat Ament and that is a freaking
awesome shirt I like to have fun
he says Daniel and Richard in cursive
down there get one at mythical dot store
support your local internet Tanner's or
us if we're not local to you we also
have these new I don't know if I'm
supposed to talk about it I notice that
I haven't seen that he's new mythical
bands there was a bunch of them out
there you probably saw when I just
walked across the room and Feldmann just
put one on my arm so I assume we're
selling those I don't know go to
mythical dot store and see I think we
will be at some point if we're not okay
let's get into some questions
what we do I'm I did I think at the end
of this podcast we're gonna talk about
something that if you're a committed
listener to ear biscuits you're gonna
want to stay to the end and if you get
bored skip to the end maybe it might be
an eight minute conversation eight
minutes I got a plan for that cuz I've
got to leave at a certain time because
we're gonna talk about the nature of
this show and what what has happened and
potentially is happening with it and I
think I just oversold something but we
are going to we're going to talk about
that at the end of this episode just
some introspection about the show itself
because I have some thoughts about and
Jacob just informed me that these
amazing new wristbands are not being
sold until early July or VidCon so if
you're going to VidCon they will be
available there that's probably why
there's so many in the office right now
because we're taking them down there
physically like this first question is
for you
oh so I'll ask it yes I'm angry Tatiana
coke lava does link have a special
ritual with Jade like the one Rhett has
with Barbara during his morning
stretches well first of all any question
that starts with does link have a
special ritual yeah it dot yes yes of
course with my beloved dog Tucker from
my adolescence I talked about the ritual
of patting him on the head
I can't actually I can't remember was it
five or seven times five because we were
I wrote about it in the book then once I
put it in the book of mythicality I just
I forgot it because I know I can
reference it there it's also a number so
yeah I don't make a habit of remembering
those I don't have anything that
ritualistic I mean Jade sleeps in the
bed with us
and then when I'm very ritualistic when
it comes to taking her outside to use
the bathroom because as is true with
dawson's or Datsuns or however you want
to say apparently you don't say Dodson
because I said that and we say dots in
the recent episode
and people are like what what is up with
the way that Josh's godson - I say the
way we're saying America okay
it runs in their lineage to be hard to
housebreak so I'm very ritualistic about
when she goes out right before we go to
bed right when we get up in the morning
but you get up and first thing like you
get what's the first thing you do when
you get out of bed do you you relieve
yourself first right I relieve myself
didn't you really as long as she stays
in the bed she's safe she actually will
not jump out of the bed on her own she
said Aviva any it works yeah she won't
go up the stairs on her own and she
won't jump in or out of the bed in her
room because we try to preserve her back
health which means we we carry around
like a queen ironically which is what I
do every morning yeah preserve my back
health huh talk more she said she would
like to talk to you more I let her look
me in the face more than you do but
besides that the main ritual we have is
whenever I lay down on the couch I
always call her up and she lays on my
chest and then we take a nap together
that's like the most special thing we do
of course we sleep together every night
I mean she sleeps in between me and
Christie and like will burrow herself
down in the bottom they like to these
dogs like to burrow in in in no vase no
suffocation concerned we were really
scared like when we first got her like
puppy she would crawl she would get
under the covers and crawl down all the
way down under our feet and I was so
nervous that she was gonna suffocate but
then we got used to it she doesn't yet
know she comes out when she gets hot she
comes out and she goes whatever she
wants and she wakes us up not by barking
but by flapping her ears that's how she
wakes us up so gentle she's a woman of
ritual herself I have a there's an
update to my Barbara ritual which I
think I last time I told you that it's
become so ritualistic and again this is
something that Barbara initiated the
first thing I do when I get out of it
well I relieve myself and then I come
back into the bedroom and I lay down
next to the bed on the rug and I began
to do my stretches and as soon as I
come back in if I have a towel in my
hand because I use a towel for this
special stretch Barbara
jumps down he like bite down on the
towel it's too difficult to explain the
as soon as I come back in she gets she
jumps off the bed she's not concerned
about her own back health and then she
gets on top of me and lays with one foot
on each side of me in her head right on
my head
Lix she licks me it's got now she just
licks me one time she's just like oh and
then she immediately used to go back and
get into bed with Jesse look I got to go
down and get on his chest and lick him
and then go but now in the past couple
of weeks she's changed your routine she
gets on top of me she gives me the one
lick and then she gets off of me
and goes to my hand to your hand she
goes to my hand and she puts and she
starts scratching at my hand cuz now she
just wants me to pet her oh and she
scratches my hand do that while you
stretch and then after she scratches my
hand a couple of times she takes her
face and she puts both of her hands on
her face she's showing me I want you to
do this to me really yes and so I do it
you she she wins huh so you're no longer
stretching no I because I'm doing this
thing where I'm rotating my my lower
body so you're in a and this my hand is
free and so I put her a little bit but
do you pet her on the head where she's
petting herself I think that she's got a
limited range of motion with her Paul
she's like you and I'll do this in fur a
good configuration of petting from my
like very limited paw shenanigans right
charades my paw charades yeah and she's
done that for a long time she's show
she's shown you how she wants to be pet
it is it pet acute or pet and she but
now she's worked it into a routine so I
it is the one with the ritual it's
irresistible
she's ritualizing she's definitely she's
in charge let's do the whole let's hear
another question this is from
Tracy dr. T made up games you played his
kids my brother and I shared a room
until we were 10 years old we had twin
beds and pretended they were our boats
the game was called guys and gals
doesn't make sense
Wow guys and gals we were obviously
super bored not sailors in boats yeah
sure man got a guy boat in a gal boat I
guess guys and gals well we you know
speaking of the book of mythicality we
talked pretty extensively about the game
that the two of us would play where we
took the nerf basketball and we would
sit down across from each other with our
legs spread and roll it into each
other's nuts which I don't we there was
what the running joke in that chapter of
the book of mythicality was what we were
going to call that game right and but I
ain't none that Hawk ellipse or
something I don't know what we ended up
calling it in the book but we got a
testicle testicle yes because there's
the net we created the ad for testicle
it's got a super slick ad it looks like
cornhole but it's got a person with her
legs spread at the you should get the
book I mean who are we kidding all right
that's the only game that I can recall
that we invented
well actually I remember we invented a
game on like a a like a conference room
type table with with white with what are
the dry erase markers and there's a
thing you can do with a dry erase marker
where it's you can kind of put your
fingers on top of if it's laying down
you put your fingers on top of it and
then you press and it will it'll like
shoot it out like backspin like with
backspin like a like a log like a
lumberjack running on a log in a river
and then he like slips off the backside
in it plunk it thrusts it forward this
might be a complicated and analogy but
picture doing that with just your
fingers like just pressing down on a dry
erase marker and it slides out from
underneath and goes across the table and
it's whoever can get the closest without
going off this edge without falling off
and then you can not be on the knock
other falls off off what do we call that
well it was kind of like shuffleboard
but we had a ridiculous name for that
nothing to do with dry erase markers
remember that's a great game if you have
a boardroom boardroom and you're bored
but a game that I think that the title
is somewhere in that the game that I
played which I don't know if you ever
came over for this but you remember
again we discussed this in the book of
mythicality but my my next-door neighbor
was Peter Dinklage growing up not the
Peter Dinklage but my Peter Dinklage and
he had when we were in like middle
school or maybe even younger
his cousin came to live with him to go
to school at Campbell University
remember that Eric and he was like the
coolest guy in the world because he was
a college student yeah but he hung out
with but like like on Friday night he
would hang with us and we invented this
mix of tag and hide-and-seek
where well there is there is an element
of tagging hi Nancy but go ahead but dis
hide-and-seek involved getting back to a
certain home base always or is it just
if you're found that's it no I think you
get in its full form you get to base and
we were just playing hide and seek you
and written at hide-and-seek no but we
played it with ace there was a tree base
and a nighttime and we all dressed up in
black in like like Eric the college
student would come out and of course now
that I think about I'm like how weird is
it it's like you know he didn't have
much of a college life but we loved it
and he would come out in a full black
sweat suit and like a black beanie it's
one thing for a college sometimes a
sleigh with middle schoolers we were in
middle school it's another thing for a
college student to get fully decked out
in order to play a game of middle school
but I look forward to it so much i I do
remember playing this a few times he got
is so intense well you you had from a
young age it seems you had this affinity
for the dark and I from a young age roof
have had what is the opposite of an
affinity a scared miss I hate it I hated
the dark I still hate the
dark you know when I take out the trash
I got him like you know I'll go around
the side of my house and I'll take out
the trash at night and then I'll run
back in the house and I had lights
installed in our freaking trashcan just
I was like I am a man I'm gonna conquer
this by installing lights at my trash
can no but you know a really good
exercise is not conquering cuz it isn't
just don't turn this into theory no it's
not that I'm not scared I'm also scared
okay turn it into therapy when I when I
have to take that first of all it's
Locke's responsibility to take the trash
down our long incline Lincoln's
responsibility but that doesn't mean
that I don't have to do it every right
exactly they're teenagers so what I have
done is I go down there and I get to the
bottom of the street and it's dark in
him there might be like a cougar or a
coyote legitimately right there could be
a legit coyote or maybe like a lion like
a floating ghost sometimes it depends on
what movie you've watched recently like
a little girl like floating like a foot
off the ground and like looking at you
with dead black eyes cool think about
that when you're out there next year
trash can but what I do is I get down
there and I just stop and I don't run
you can't run
and I embrace it I'd say I'm going to
absorb whatever this is and just stay
here and take it until it goes away
and then I'm going to demonic power and
then I'm going to just absorb the
demonic power and then I'm going to
slowly walk up I'm gonna resist the urge
to run like sorry don't run you get
given you walk slowly and confidently
the thing I love about your anecdote is
that admitted that you're just as afraid
as I am but I don't show it you're just
more prideful than I am no it's part of
the therapy okay I guess like smiling to
induce happiness walk confidently to get
rid of scared miss what were we talking
about I don't know but I'm gonna move on
to another question
sherry things you thought were true for
the longest time and how you found out
about it Oh
I've got one for this listen I think
reddit is is is becoming too big a part
of my night life because those are your
nighttime activities now reddit no it's
not what's part of it I go to sleep look
at it read it now well I don't actually
fall well I have I do fall asleep
sometimes would like my phone hits my
chest now that's dangerous
hopin there's read it on you can
accidentally if you especially if you do
that on Twitter you can accidentally end
up liking something well I'm just sleepy
hold on
I'm just saying you gotta be careful do
not on like ambien or I'm saying be no
no it's like as it's like falling like
if you're looking at something you're
like oh that's crazy and then it like
falls on your face and you're not liking
oh I'm knows like something yeah I mean
it there's lots of different ways that
can happen
be careful as soon as I get sleepy I put
my phone down cuz it's dangerous at that
point well I don't think it's good to
shove a screen in your face right before
you go to sleep every night anyway
circadian Lee speaking circadian Lee
speaking
but this blew my mind there was a post
not too long ago and I think it was
worded like I'm 36 or I'm 43 years old
and it's taken me this long to figure
out that a bird of paradise plant is not
the head like it's not a salt it's not
the head of a kooky bird it's the entire
body of a bird where the the nose of the
bird is pointing back towards the stem
from which the flower comes and the
wings are out and the wings are out I
don't think a lot of people I think most
people were under the impression that I
definitely was under the same impression
that you're under that it was a curse I
was a big-headed bird
sticking his head out of like a bush and
like we had these in my old house like
every day in the driveway I would get in
and out of the car at least two times a
day I would see these things whenever
they were blooming and I never once saw
it the correct way
or why is that the correct way though
well because if you look at a bird of
paradise it it looks like one right
because a bird of paradise isn't some
big stork looking thing yeah what what
that interpretation of it would be any
in it just blew my mind and I told I
showed it to Christie because she's
super into plants you know that's her
that's how she gets going really sure
some plants her mind was your plant
costume her her might have a tree man
cause it exploded I got a bargain show
up and warm things oh can I borrow that
oh sure I wouldn't come inside I just
stayed out in the yard and then there
are other there are other plants no not
other plants there are other reddit
posts where people live like literally
taking googly eyes and either Photoshop
or in real life have placed eyes on the
two different places that could indicate
where the head in the face of the to
make the big-headed bird or the or the
the small one that kind of list looks
like a hummingbird in flight it's not as
impressive as the big-headed bird no but
it made a lot more sense but did she did
she know this all no she was she was
with us yeah I think most people are you
know what to something that I've also
been because it looks like a beak a lot
of people have been talking about but
it's the tail and I think there was a
Twitter moment about this weeks ago all
these people are realizing that Donald
Glover and childish gambino are the same
person like that is happening and that
kind of yeah
that kind of blew my mind a little bit
yeah because I totally understand how it
depends on how you were introduced to
the two different facets of his career
but I mean it's I guess it's very easy
to listen to and enjoy his music but not
watch a music video or see his face
attached to it no but I think people
because it's previous album you know he
it's not like he's on the cover but I
think these are people who have my guess
is they've seen him do his thing as
childish game be Bebo Gambino and
then still not put it together because
the way that people reveal that they
finally understood this yes like this
mind-blowing thing that you're like oh
oh oh this is the same person but that
did not happen to me
I knew yeah I knew birds-of-paradise
they got me I'm not gonna shame anyone
for thinking I don't love her did not
get me I get it I'll never look at a
bird of paradise the same way again
matter of fact I'll never look at one
again ha I win well there's two in my
front yard
I will avert my eyes this is from Emily
your money SS Dec 27 was your favorite
memory from GMM ear biscuits and/or the
tour of mythicality
mine was meeting you guys nice to meet
you Emily I could see that your profile
picture is the meeting that we had must
have been meaningful that's cool I can't
tell which stop that was well that's it
for us Emily meeting you yep seems like
that has to be our answer and it is you
know what that's our answer but what's
the second highlight besides meeting
Emily um I think one of the highlights
of the tour mythicality that has come up
multiple times is when we went to
Washington DC I could easily figure it
out but I can't quite figure it out off
the top of my head where we went from DC
but Philadelphia I think so
we brought Lily with us and so bringing
Lily for that little leg of the tour was
was a highlight for me but then she
always talks about you know we did and
if you watched the rhettandlink
Instagram we did some stories where we
were on the mall and we did we did the
whole mall thing boy that was a
highlight but then she always talks
about I don't know she just brings it up
a lot she's like remember that time when
we were in Washington DC and it was
freezing outside and we came out of the
museum we were like really hungry and
there were all of those food trucks
there and there was that one that had
like the lamb and
chicken plates and we we each got one
and it was so windy but we sat outside
and we ate them and I'm like yeah I
remember that she was like that's one of
the best meals I've ever had
oh really you know it's one of those you
know the the best meal you've ever had
in in quotes it's so much about the
surrounding experience so it just feels
it always makes me feel great when she
brings that up because as good as I know
that that food was and it was good it
was very good she's basically saying we
created a memory and you happen to be
there - Rhett I was there there's a good
meal so that bested me that was that was
that was certainly a highlight and then
her kind of assisting us I could you
know I could tell that like she was glad
to be there and she felt like she's part
of the team and she's the only she's the
only child between the two of us who
would be capable of offering any sort of
help yeah in in the in that capacity she
got some tea she got some throat coat
before we went onstage he reminds me of
the time well the whole the whole
chicken and rice thing then is is
unrelated but so the hollow guys in in
Manhattan who had a food truck a food
cart that we actually featured in our
very very very old food cart song which
was in 2008 so 10 years ago as part of
the alka-seltzer great American road
trip we did this song about food cart
people and has a good message we're
doing that song we were introduced to
this what was at the time probably the
most famous food cart in the nation yeah
since then they've expanded from so it's
basically chicken and rice and they've
got like a white sauce and a hot sauce
and it's you can get even get lamb or
chicken or both oh and you should get
both it's funny how in its Ennis I mean
a lot of food trucks and food carts
serve this particular dish but they did
it in a special way so much here's the
funny thing and it's still there you can
go there 10 years later my perspective
is change
significantly on this right because in
2008 I never really had chicken lamb and
rice in that fashion mm-hmm now living
in Los Angeles I mean I literally cannot
walk seven feet without having chicken
or rice hit my face you know I'm saying
it rains it right and that that style of
kind of like a Middle Eastern style of
chicken and rice is everywhere and so I
we don't really go back and getting go
to that cart anymore we did one time
when we went with Stevie and we're all
out there at like 2:00 a.m. eating this
chicken and rice and I was like I don't
know if this was worth it yeah because
I've had a lot of chicken and rice in
sand but we would go there I would that
was not a good experience for me because
I got that sick yeah I was really sick
yeah you got sick we haven't been back
to the cart since then and now I
remember we were sitting with like we
had gotten this we were like building it
up to Stevie we're like we got to take
you to this to get these dis halal guys
we got to get a tray and then there's no
you know and then we're going and we're
sitting against a building like and I
didn't figure so I was like sitting down
and you guys are standing up and there
were some businessmen there you remember
that yeah and they started talking they
started talking to us and they didn't
realize that I was sick we didn't want
to talk and I really didn't want to talk
and so in the middle of the conversation
because I started standing I remember I
just kind of slid down the the side of
the building and sat and put my head
between my knees and it was kind of I
created kind of an awkward moment with
these businessmen they slowly walked
away at that point I do remember that I
think they made fun of me a little bit
that guy's having a problem
food poisoning perhaps I don't know now
those guys have not from the hello guys
whatever was before before that they've
got a they've got like an actual
restaurant in Glendale yeah I haven't
been to that but people don't people
don't review it well and I think it's
because there's so much good food in
that style out here that he you know I
didn't necessarily stand as much
a chance I don't mean there's your
highlight so the one thing I will say
about favorite memory from GMM makes me
think is a though I don't remember much
from GMM until somebody asks a specific
question about something or Shepherd
which Shepherd binge watches GMM and
help go deep uh-huh okay he doesn't
watch it on a regular basis but
sometimes you he'll would you just
you'll find him at the downstairs
computer and he's going through it just
laughing so it does make me feel good
that he he thinks that we're funny yeah
that's good he's got good taste but
sometimes I'll find him watching
something like oh yeah as long as he
finds us funny he that good did that
happened so I that's how I find out my
memories he's by seeing them again on my
own home computer link another question
for you
from Brittany the renewed link do you
ever wish you had siblings do you think
your lack of siblings influenced your
relationship or your friendship with
Rhett I'm Rhett that's me I am an only
child but I do have siblings I have a
let's see my dad my dad and my mom had
me my dad got remarried and had two more
kids who are my half siblings right so I
got a half sister and a half brother
together they make a whole sibling yeah
and that whole sibling spread across two
distinct and wonderful individuals are
people that I've never lived with and
you know I actually don't see them that
often now so it's not you know we don't
we don't have that strong of a
relationship but my book christy is
Facebook friends with Lauren who is my
half-sister yeah and there were over the
years there was like lots of variables
which kept us from being actually having
a like a vibrant relationship I'll just
leave it at that
but it's not that we're on bad terms and
so nothing about my opinion has to do
with my relationship or interactions
with them my but I am strongly of the
opinion when I talked to someone who is
has a kid I'm like hey do you haven't
have any kids yeah we got one I'm like
okay well you need to have another one
don't do that to the I kind of I kind of
make light of it I've seen this in
action do I make it awkward when I do
that cuz it's like people usually this
conversation is when you're having with
someone you're just meeting
I do believe talk about how many kids
and for someone just to come out and say
have another one I will say it's it's
safe to say the unsolicited family
planning advice to people you just met
risky is not necessarily the best course
of action but the way that I say it I
say well have another one cuz you don't
want to do it you don't want to do that
to to your first child I'm an only child
you don't want him to turn out like me
hahaha that's kind of a self-deprecating
gentleman comes back to you but it's
like that because like an only child
right exactly exactly I I you know I I
do feel like I missed out on a lot I
think that I'm soft because I don't have
any siblings the thing that I've
observed about my kids is that they give
each other such a hard time they get on
each other's nerves so much that is
ultimately a healthy thing it builds a
thick skin and it also I really think it
helps them understand that like there's
plenty of times and at this age I think
they would say the majority of the time
they don't like each other but they know
that they love each other you know it's
not you know you say well you got to
love each other it's like and they're
too smart to tell each other they love
each other usually and special special
occasions are question of intelligence
it'll eke out but they're my kids but
that's that we have to tell them we have
to tell them to do that to say they love
each other but I think they know deep
down
that they are experiencing true familial
love and there but they annoyed the crap
out of each other and I just think
that's a really healthy thing to be
exposed to and not think that you know
it's your this what you're the center of
the world well I am and I I think I was
definitely spoiled and I was not I was
not punished for things you know this I
mean you got you would always get
frustrated when we would get in trouble
for something and then you get punished
and go home and get punished for it come
to school the next day and and blow what
about you I'll be like nothing I'm cool
man
I got no punish yeah well I got one I
think that was just your mom's style of
discipline but yeah yeah I mean I mean
theoretically it does make sense that
you know so so by that rationale you
definitely are very special filter the
only so more kids it's not healthy to be
the more brothers the more brothers and
sisters you have the more deference
there is to other people's needs and I
think that that probably makes you more
likely to like because again when
there's a the parent and the child very
different roles of course it kind of
goes without saying but it's just like
when a parent does something for a child
whether they get you a dessert or they
get you they get you a present or
whatever when it's just a parent giving
that to one child then they're on the
receiving end of that but like you know
almost as a point of an opportunity for
teaching like we get our kids a dessert
that they have to split and it's they
it's horrible it actually makes it
sometimes you want to get them each
their own thing because you don't want
to deal with them fighting over getting
exactly it - exactly split in the right
proportions oh yeah but I have to
believe that that practice over time
does make people more more willing to
defer in certain situations I mean don't
you feel like I mean Cole's what 3 or 4
years old in here 3 yeah do you feel
like you I mean what what do you think
is the chief benefit
of him being there he helped you with
your interest in music helped you get on
to the right hip-hop thurid's well I
mean yeah I meant yeah all that this
especially as a younger brother like
there's all the things that you get i
wouldn't know who kool Moe Dee was you
know and that's and that's a big thing
for me now
right right Queen Latifah well I well I
think it's what I just said I think it's
and again this is also I don't know
we're not in sighs child psychologist do
we have to remind you what you jealous
of him I like it that way well yeah I
don't you know I don't think there was
as much I don't I see this between my
kids lots of things of like LOC saying I
would never have gotten away with that I
think my parents were actually much more
conscious about being consistent
consistent in their discipline and their
standards from older to younger kids in
a way that we've relaxed ourselves I
know you have as well with each one
that's gone down it's just like Lando
can do whatever he wants to so can
Shepherd pretty much yeah who knows
what's gonna happen with those kids but
I to me I think it's and I do think that
it you can make this adjustment later on
in life especially like you know then
you we shared a room in college you
lived with other people and now you live
with Christie so I think that but you
may have had more challenges to overcome
with kind of giving somebody else their
space and and accommodating someone
else's preferences but I think you you
have you being like particular about
things I don't think that's the result
of being a child I think that's just
your personality makeup but like
carabaos ER but I might I might have
gotten better at stepping outside of it
earlier because I most certainly would
have had to do that if I had another
sibling now I will point out that I
lived with a stepsister from grade
kindergarten the
third grade so I did I did have a I
guess I did live with a sibling but he's
weird because I see Amy was like I think
it was five years older than me so I do
think it starts to make a difference
because I didn't see her as my bonafide
sister I was I was very annoyed by her
but we didn't
I don't recall us doing that much
together we each there was a pretty big
age difference and girl and guy I don't
know I mean one of the things that I'm
kind of exploring in my life journey at
this point is trying to deconstruct my
personality and understand why I am the
way that I am in one and so I've always
thought of myself as very independent
right you know so you know when I went
off to college even I was you know I was
only an hour away from home but in my
mind I didn't talk to my mom or dad
again until Thanksgiving now I know I
probably ended up calling them but I did
not I did not call my parents a lot I
still don't
mm-hmm and I'm pretty independent like I
don't like to receive help for things
you know I'm uncomfortable with getting
help and I like if I faced with a
problem the first thing I do is just try
to figure it out on my own and always
just thought that like that was a super
positive thing and I'm just an
independent person I'm not a needy
person I don't like to be needy I don't
in a group of people I don't want to be
the person who complains about something
I don't want to be the person that
everyone is having to adjust their
course of action because of me and my
needs and I always thought that this was
a positive thing in some senses it is a
positive thing but one of something I'm
around me it is go ahead something that
I'm learning is that there's probably a
time in my life probably between the
time I was like three four and five when
there was a circumstances in my life
whether that was something with my
parents or something with my my you know
my brother where we were at the time
something I was going through
where I began to kind of put up a little
bit of kind of thing like I'm going to
take care of things on my own and I had
an incredible childhood I you know
intact home very stable very loving
parents and so there's not like some you
know initial event that I can point to
anything like that but I'm kind of
discovering that some of you basically
put on this shell of a personality that
helps you cope with whatever you're
dealing with and then you kind of carry
that well into adulthood and then if you
begin to kind of do some work on
yourself and deal yourself you begin to
realize that oh part of that shell that
I put on myself to kind of make it into
adulthood is unnecessary now in fact
it's a hindrance for me understanding
Who I am
in dealing properly with my own emotions
because that's what another thing I've
always thought I'm just not an emotional
guy you know it's like in Jesse and I
talk about this in our relationship you
know she's like I you know sometimes I
just feel like you're not as present as
you should be or you're you just don't
seem to be as passionate about this at
times as I would like you to be and I'm
like well I'm just you know I'm just not
a needy guy no I don't wear my emotions
on my sleeve and I'm but it turns out
that there's a portion of that that I'm
figuring out that is ultimately
unhealthy and so what ends up happening
is I actually am experiencing emotions
because everybody is experiencing
emotions but then it'll come out
sideways and like snapping at the kids
or snapping at Jesse or potentially in
some sort of physical manifestation of
not properly channeling my emotions just
beginning to kind of get into this and
deal with this but I'm not like a
vestigial arm yeah I have an arm that I
have not told anybody about an emotional
it's on my lower back and I will reveal
it in season 14 of good mythical morning
but it's made up of pure pent up emotion
I don't know exactly where I'm going
with that but I ultimately I guess the
question that got us into this is the
whole sibling thing so you're saying
your brother screwed my brother Costas
and
but but I think that what well I know
what every where I was going with this I
would think that while there are certain
ways that kids who are in families of
like you know six seven eight kids would
be super self-sufficient they may have
some emotional work to do later in life
because they had to defer their own
needs so much to kind of be a part of a
family that was that big which again
makes you a person that's easy to get
along with that's another thing I've
always easy to get along with I don't I
don't complain about a lot of things I
don't cause trouble in a group but it
also there's a negative side to that
with I'm holding I end up holding things
in and I don't even experience in them
I don't experience them personally in a
way that maybe you are better at because
you didn't have to hold any of that in
because you were most of the time was
just you and your mom and my GI Joes so
so in other words you may have some
different challenges but you also may
have some things some benefits from that
so all that to say you probably
shouldn't be giving unsolicited family
planning advice to people with one kid
they should just do whatever they feels
best in their family and see how it
turns out yeah they're gonna be kids are
gonna be screwed up no matter what and
they're gonna have to work through the
crap because their human journey yes
journey rain that's a name journey rain
yep she does that almost sounds made-up
should be a weather person I don't know
what you do but if you ever choose to be
a weather person we will support you
what is something super nostalgic for
you guys whether whether she used the
term weather in this but not spelled
that way yeah but it's whether it's a
smell or a taste or something you see
that will remind you of something from
your past a weird and I think this will
be our last question what unless I make
it like precisely quick because I want
no because I want to be able to have the
conversation that you teased oh that's
right I got to get to the DI doctor
maybe I'm remembering this because we
were talking about the tour
Akala t but this is what popped into my
head I experienced like a high spike of
nostalgia when we went to that one those
this one venue that we went to I'll
describe it to you maybe you can help me
remember which city it's in because they
all started to run together for us but
don't you don't you remember we were we
the first time we saw the venue lots of
times we would be coming from backstage
and then going out on the stage to do a
soundcheck and I remember looking out at
the seats and I'm like oh crap it's the
Buies Creek auditorium seats yeah I
don't remember it was but I do remember
you pointing it out and I definitely
agree and they and it was a specific
model of like wooden seat that was like
a curved back seat with like the it had
a liner wider stained wood that had been
worked into a pattern amongst the seats
and then the seat bottom would you know
like a theater seat it would go up and
then when you sat on it it would go down
I think it was Philadelphia I don't know
it wasn't yeah it was an old venue and
it was the exact same model of seats
that I have not seen anywhere else
since Buies Creek Elementary School and
I remember sitting in those seats as it
as a fidgety little kid you know for all
the school assemblies from like
kindergarten all the way through eighth
grade and you'd sit you'd sit down and I
remember the feeling of that seat just
going down and then there were a few
seats that were broken and you knew not
to sit in those but then some people
wouldn't know and they would sit in it
and it would like burp it would go
sideways and you'd fall and then there
were some of the wood on some of them on
the backs of some of them won't be
stripped off because these kids would be
real fidgety and they would start to
grab it and strip away that
oh yeah the wood and it's it's crazy how
something can trigger memories to that
level and I could smell Buies Creek
auditorium you know auditorium smell
wood and lacquer now it didn't smell
like the room we were in
but I but my memory made me access that
smell and usually it works in the
opposite way where you like smell
something that'll trigger memories I
have well like a new longer a new way to
get to a memory I have a stronger boys
creak smell that recently hit me yeah
and maybe this has happened to you
because this has happened a few times so
Locke was doing some basketball event at
a at this old gym at an old school
somewhere in town I don't remember
exactly where but I had to take a whiz
as you do where's wish I'm not talking
about the movie which I highly recommend
that's the Wiz I had to just take a whiz
and I went into the boys bathroom and it
smelled exactly like the Buies Creek
Elementary boys bathroom now and I got
like a mixture of like stale urinal
water but the thing I want to understand
is because it's just it's it's tile it's
like that green that light green tile
and those old style urinals mm-hmm and
built like a tank
yeah all the way to the ground the ones
that Buies Creek didn't go all over the
ground these did and I was trying to
figure out what is it I'm smelling
because it's not I think it's the pipes
and a certain water tight and then urine
like like just baked in your like
elementary urine
yeah likes different young juice boxes
youngster urine sweet ass acidophilus
milk carton remember remember that I
didn't know what that milk was I never
got that milk I would always get the
chocolate milk I was so picky I didn't
even like their chocolate milk it wasn't
it wasn't the exact right type of Chuck
maybe there's something about like a
public school diet in the way that it
interacts with you you know like a six
to twelve year old boy
yeah and then the pipes anyway it's not
a pleasant smell I wouldn't like to turn
it into a fragrance you know in reckon
no did it did a specific memory flash
into your mind as a result of that yeah
I was peeing
I was whizzing and the memory of Maurice
Cameron coming up behind me while I was
whizzing yeah and tapping me on the butt
while i was whizzing tapping you on the
back you know like you you you
somebody's in the middle of peeing and
you come up and you like kick them with
your foot so a little bit so so you make
so it wasn't a tap as much as a light
push right it was to get you to squeeze
and stop yeah stop the stream yeah and
then and actually I've been I I've been
trying to recover for that oh yeah 38
years it's very difficult for me to pee
in front of another individual I get
what do you call I want to say camera
shy what do you want trigger-happy way
what do you call it when you can't be in
front of somebody something shy with shy
performance it's like performance
anxiety it's not that it's something
else but I'll remember it later when
it's unimportant but I feel like III
link that back to being any cuz he he
kind of had that was his thing he
Maurice mess you up and so I'm always
thinking is more he's gonna come up
behind me while I'm standing at the
airport next to this guy wondering who's
good who's P is going to hit the water
first you know he's like this ghost of
Maurice I should write a short story
called the ghost of Maurice he's not
dead I don't know if he is or not I hope
he's not he shouldn't be
no they're just lightly tapping people
as this is don't I don't think he ever
did that to me because I don't have any
problems just letting it whiz but what
about yesterday dude when we whizzed
what are you talking about when what you
and I whizzed in that in that bathroom
like we went to a meeting and then after
the meeting oh yeah we we had to whiz
and we had to get the key from the from
the reception receptionist and then go
unlock the door and we unlocked the door
and there there's a three sinks in a
urinal and then two stalls and we had to
go to the stalls because there was a guy
in at the urinal he was a security guard
yeah and I I thought he greeted us when
we walked in
but then I realized he wasn't talking to
us he was talking to himself but then I
started to think oh he's not talking to
himself I think he's talking to God
because he look at it it sounded like he
was praying I heard the words he said
delicioso which I thought was Italian
delicioso
and he also said hey Seuss so he said
delicious Jesus as far as I could tell
and you know what I heard Jesus while
peeing and I mean but he was also I
thought he might be on the phone a lot
of phone now ladies I'll just let you
know a lot of times when you when you go
into a men's restroom and there's older
men in there and they're whizzing
there's a lot of like like like signing
like the grunting the deepest relief you
can imagine and all of us are making
that sound in our minds and then some of
us as we break a certain threshold of
age just let it happen all because he
was also thinking Jesus for the
delicious moment and it was it sounded
just like this and it sounds like a
chant because it repeated I heard Jesus
more than once but he said hey Suz which
was Spanish but that's true but then he
said delicioso which is that and then
the weaves go into a stall next to each
other and you were talking to me a
little bit about something but then it
got quiet and I was like I was just
about to start busting out laughing yeah
cuz this guy the whole time he was
chanting looks like he didn't know we're
there or something he did know because
that we made our entrance I mean it was
obvious there were other people in there
a small bathroom and and I thought maybe
hey Suz responded because it got quiet
for a second and all of a sudden I heard
and I was like nope that's not a that's
not an act of God no it was just a fart
and then it's like it released another
valve then he was able to pee some more
well you never know man hey we're
heading that way real fast what yeah
whatever it takes George I'm sure we'll
speak about it in depth when we discover
the
of how how the way to open the the door
the kidney door to like it another valve
okay let's just buy farty you got six
minutes to make your make your speech
you don't have eight is that right yeah
I mean I gotta good you have to leave it
at 20 after no that's when the
appointment is oh there's nothing wrong
with your eyes man don't worry about it
I have to go back I've already postponed
this appointment one time and they
charge me for it well those are all the
questions we're gonna take today and we
want to thank you for submitting those
again all the social medias is how you
communicate with us hashtag ear biscuits
but the thing I want to get to is first
of all I want to invite you to think of
consider sharing this podcast with
somebody who is not a fan of good
mythical morning or has never listened
to ear biscuits I the thing that I'm
realizing is I think that this show is
evolving and definitely over this past
year we we we made a decision to not
have guests and to settle in to just us
having conversations and even though we
made that decision we're still trying to
figure out exactly what your biscuits is
but I think it's really taking shape and
I think we're beginning to understand
but it's I think we're in a difficult
position because we're the ones talking
and doing this and kind of going on
instinct to characterize what show is
but just as a thought starter mm-hmm
again it's open to further definition
but I would say at this point it is a
open and honest conversation between two
lifelong friends who may or may not be
funny to you that is often driven by
questions that are submitted and
sometimes just driven by experiences
that these two guys have there's
probably a more catchy like bumper
sticker way to describe that but it's
not subject based it's not about any
particular thing but if you think that
there's somebody out there and I'm glad
you mentioned like somebody who's not a
fan idea man because I think that
because GMM has gotten so popular and it
is the thing that 90% of people who know
who we are know us through and either
like it or you don't and I think you
have a certain conception of what GMM is
and usually it's those guys who eat
testicles on the internet and if you're
not into that then you think you just
sort of say okay I'm gonna kind of write
these guys off but there's I think
there's a lot of people out there who
would enjoy the conversations that we
have who may not enjoy the things that
we do that are a little lower brow on GM
now we enjoy both and we're glad to have
you if you enjoy both and listen to both
so we're not you know we're not saying
anything negative about your tastes
because I mean that makes us feel good
that you like both aspects of what we're
doing but we do want to acknowledge that
the people who are who are telling us
that we were meeting fans in person
we're seeing tweets it's like ear
biscuits I really got into this like I'm
a huge fan and this is what I I just
love it and you can tell that they may
not even know about good mythical
morning and I think we're encouraged by
that and I think it's it opens up the
possibility for you to maybe share this
podcast or something with someone who
has a similar sensibility to these type
of conversations maybe it is endeavoring
creatively like we are or as a husband a
wife or a parent or is just someone
who's finding themselves getting older
or all the things we talk about like
it's it's weird for us to like
overanalyze what what what we bring to
this so what I think ultimately we kind
of leave it to you but we want to invite
you to think about sharing this podcast
with someone who either has a reference
for GMM or doesn't have a point of
reference at all for what we're doing
and I would say that you may know
somebody who listens to podcast because
it typically goes that if you listen to
podcasts you listen to podcasts and you
don't just listen to
one mhm I mean I may be some of you this
is the only podcast you listen to and
you haven't move on to anything else but
and that's fine but so maybe you know
somebody who's looking for there are
certain people a certain kind of
lifestyle where they want to have
something in their ear while they're
doing something else and that's really
what podcast is great for I love it
while I'm working out I love listening
to stuff well I'm well I'm working out
or while I'm driving so if you know
people who are into that kind of thing
recommend your biscuits to them but then
maybe you're the kind of person who this
was the first podcast that you listen to
and this was an introduction to the
world of podcasting and you're like oh I
never thought that I had an appetite for
this kind of content now I do that may
be a way to talk about it again the
whole point here is that we want to keep
doing this the more people that listen
to this the more sense it makes for us
to continue doing it it's just kind of
how this this thing works because it is
it while it's a passion and it's also a
release for us and I think part of our
friendship is our is is based on these
conversations that we have now a lot of
times that we save to have in front of
you guys but this is also a business
that's why we have sponsors that's why
we say the podcast is supported by
fill-in-the-blank is because this is a
this is a part of the greater business
and metal mythical entertainment so the
more people that are listening the
better it is for the entertainment that
we're creating and ultimately this whole
show is supported by you so we want to
thank you for listening and telling us
what you think specifically about this
use hashtag ear biscuits yeah you
becomes before the I we will talk to you
next week
[Music]